Whoa!
Everybody!
Did you guys like the beginning of the stream where we all started out with the penguin me?
Yes!
I am... I am a professional.
Wow!
So professional!
Doki!
I would like to say a huge shout out to Fast Penguin and Historia for the sponsor for today.
Yes, this is a sponsored stream by the way.
This is a sponsored stream.
So they paid me to check out their game.
And it seems really fun honestly.
I mean it's free to play so... I mean I like that part a lot.
I mean...
Everybody likes free stuff.
So this game is free to play, free to download.
So you can hop on in Dragoons if you want to.
You can check out the link and the pinned messages and in the description to download the game.
And it really helps the stream a lot as well.
It really helps the sponsor and it really helps the stream.
So you can join in and play some lobbies with me.
I'm gonna be doing like public matchmaking first.
But they also have custom lobbies.
So later on we're gonna try out the public matchmaking.
And then later on we're gonna try out custom lobbies.
So the Dragoons can like join in with me as well.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna... Oh there we go.
Apparently people were telling me that the BGM is great.
It really is though.
It really is.
But someone was like, oh my god.
My brain is melting.
It's not happening for any of this.
It gets me excited for Penguins.
Alright.
I plugged in my controller.
So I'm gonna play on the Roller.
Because it's basically, for those who don't know, what fast Penguin is.
Oh.
Woah.
You can have a fucking pig?
Oh wait.
Give me a sec.
Let me double check if I can swear.
Oh.
Okay, I... okay, yes, okay.
Let me double that.
I was like, oh no, wait, I don't remember if I'm left to curse.
I'm going to try not to.
I'm going to try not to curse today, chat.
Anyway, I'm a very professional.
Anyway, so for those who don't know, this is basically like a battle royale racing game, which is a very interesting concept.
You know, never heard of a battle royale game for racing in general, but like you're not racing cars, you're racing penguins.
And the game is out on Steam.
I believe it's on Steam, PlayStation 5, and the Epic Game Store.
But they're going to... it's going to come out on the Switch and the Xbox series soon.
So for now, you can only get it on the PlayStation 5.
See, I told you PS5 has games.
The Epic Game Store and Steam, and they're all... and there is cross-platform play.
So it supports cross-platform, and it is, like I said, it's free.
So if you guys want to download the game, like I said, it's pinned in the description.
Sorry, it's in the description.
I'm sorry.
It's 1230.
Dad woke me up several times.
It's 8 in the morning, because apparently, there was an inspection today, and I didn't realize there was a goddamn inspection today, so they woke me up at 8 in the morning, because they're like, they're like, hello, we're here to inspect your house, your apartment,
and I'm like, it's 8 in the morning.
This one of mine is a little jumbled up right now.
Anyway, as I was saying, the link is in the description, and it's pinned in the chat, so if you guys want to check it out as well, and download the game and play with me.
Each lobby supports, like, 40 players, which is a lot.
That's a lot.
And there's, like, solo mode, which supports 40 players, and you can also, like, duo, trio, quadruple, I don't know, four stack.
Duo, trio, four stack in party mode.
And, like I said, there is private lobbies, so I can make a custom lobby later.
And you can also customize your penguin and everything.
Do I have clothes?
Oh, oh, I can give myself a new yellow.
Okay, I can be a naked penguin.
Oh, I got a skateboard?
Oh my god, I got a whale?
Oh, wait, I can say hi to people.
Oh, okay, nice.
Hi.
Oh, that's so cute!
Wait, that's so cute!
I can be...
I can be naked!
Nice.
Oh, wait, I want to have...
Wait!
I don't want to be naked.
That means I'm poor.
I want to have this outfit!
No!
Never mind, guys.
I don't want to be naked anymore, because people will think I'm a poor penguin.
Anyway, so we're going to try out the first game here.
This is a large-scale online multiplayer game.
Complete all four activities and aim for the podium.
The number of people can clear each activity is limited.
Oh, yeah, so there's four different games until the final.
So, like, you get eliminated per activity.
And then you get to the final and then you get the crown.
So, the player with the highest points basically...
Oh, wait, what's else?
X.
Okay.
Oh, that's so cool!
The moment...
It changes the control input on there.
Okay.
Kick and jump off enemies.
To quickly pass rivals in one go.
If you fail, you won't be able to attack for a while.
Okay.
Collect 10 cans of sardines to use the ultimate ride.
Get in the lead by kicking others out of the way.
If you're lucky enough to obtain the paraglider ball, it's a game changer.
Glide through the air to first place.
Also, how's the volume?
Is everything okay for the volume?
Yeah, I think it's like...
Yeah, I think...
I think it could be like Fall Guys and Mario Kart.
It seems really fun.
In concept.
That's it from me.
Bon voyage!
Is the music...
You're just a hater.
I like how someone's like, Game background music is a bit soft.
And someone else is like, Music is too loud.
Someone's just a hater.
No!
Turn it down!
Please!
Welcome to my world!
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna be a PG here.
Alright.
We're queuing up.
Guys, queue up, guys.
You might be able to be in my lobby, guys.
Queue up.
Wait, what's in the shop?
Can I look at the shop while I'm in queue?
I assume I can, right?
Oh, I can!
The weather is nice today.
Don't you think so?
Wait, I can like, Ride on a burger.
Oh my god!
Wait, what's this?
I cannot get on a luggage?
Wait, this is so cute.
I can put stickers on my luggage.
Oh my god!
I can be a cat!
I can be...
Alright.
Hey, guys.
Hey.
Oh!
Guys!
Please!
Friendly!
Hello, everybody!
Hello!
Yeah!
Wait, how do I...
How do you guys do this?
Oh, nice!
Wait, how come that guy...
Goddamn!
Bumped me like that!
Guys.
Oh, that's how they do it!
They slap me!
Oh, okay.
Guys, I got this, guys.
Guys, no!
No, you have a pineapple!
You're a gamer!
It's not fair!
Oh, what's this?
Oh, it's not fair!
I'm gonna slap you.
No, I wanted to slap!
How do I slap?
Oh!
Okay.
That's how you slap, guys.
Wow!
That's right.
Get out of the way!
Get slapped.
Okay.
Hello, beach.
Oh!
Hello, everybody.
Friendly?
Oh, so like, basically, you'll miss.
No!
Wait!
Get away!
No!
It's not fair!
I didn't realize it's not fair!
I didn't realize it's not fair.
Okay.
That's illegal!
How did they get the paraglider?
Are they cheating?
That's right!
Yeah!
Mine!
That's right!
Yeah!
I ain't afraid to slap you!
That's right!
Oh, you see that?
No!
Cops!
Police!
They slapped me!
That's right!
Oh, you thought you could slap me?
That's goddamn right!
That's right!
Get out of the way!
Cops!
No!
Did anyone get the number?
I could have slapped you in time!
No!
I got...
Oh, I thought I died.
I thought I died there.
Did anyone get her number?
Wait, 17?
Wait, I must make it!
I must make it!
Yes!
Oh, I just barely made it!
That's right!
Yeah, that's right.
I'm a gamer.
It's so goddamn opposite!
That's right!
37 points!
Where am I?
Oh, this is me!
Guys, get out of the way!
I wanna...guys!
I wanna be on the camera!
So easy!
I made it in!
I already made it into the next round, chat!
Already made it in!
That's right!
I know how to slap!
Alright, I'll do that after I die, which will be in like...okay, now the recovery was pretty good, okay?
Guys, not gonna lie, after, like, the really bad recovery, not gonna...
Like, you have to admit, after the incredibly terrible recovery, like, I sorry, I recovered pretty well.
Like, it was pretty bad.
What?
Don't say it!
Don't say it, Doki!
Don't...I know you wanna say something!
Don't say it!
It's not fair!
They're all bumping into me!
That's right!
You bump into me, you get slapped!
That's goddamn right!
What?!
Whose thing was that?!
No!
Oh, thank god!
Okay, that's fine.
That's right!
Mine now!
Yoink!
Oh, god!
No!
I missed!
Okay, top 70%, that's okay!
That's okay!
That's alright, Doki!
We're still in it!
We just gotta wait until somebody gets close to you so you can...STOP!
That's right!
Let's go!
I have my big buddy here!
That's goddamn right!
Get out of here!
Know your place!
Know your goddamn place!
Oh, come on!
Yes!
I made it!
Goal!
The timing!
She let the toxicity for him!
Oh, yeah!
Okay!
I bet!
I bet you have!
Frick you!
Don't say it, Doki!
Don't say it!
This is PG!
You know you wanna say it, but you can't!
Don't say it, Doki!
Oh, good!
Must learn!
Guys, no!
Guys, please!
We wanna look good in front of the sponsors!
Don't encourage me!
Don't encourage me, guys!
Say it with your inside voice!
No, no, no!
Don't hit me!
Oh, no!
Come on!
Oh, my gosh!
I need to slap you!
Let me slap you!
Seriously!
You're slapping range!
Yes!
Oh, my God!
The moment when they're in slapping range, guys!
Ooh!
The moment when they're in slapping range!
Oh, no!
How did he get, like, ten already?
I've only got six!
Okay, that's fine.
You!
Don't say it!
It's okay!
I didn't say it!
I was...
I was peachy!
I just tried so hard!
I mean, these penguins!
These penguins!
No!
You penguin!
You stupid penguin!
That's not!
That's peachy!
I'm calling him stupid and peachy!
Guys!
I'm in!
You bad penguins!
It's okay!
Okay, cat penguin got it instead of, like, goddamn pineapple penguin!
You don't deserve it!
I literally just played the game today!
That's worse!
Okay, final race!
Final race, guys!
This is it!
Please!
I'm just new here!
I'm a new gamer!
I'm just a beginner!
I'm, like...
My Oshie's saying, no, no.
How did I get so far?!
Oh, my god!
They must be cheating!
I refused!
No!
You bad penguin!
I'm gonna slap you first!
No, I couldn't slap him first!
I couldn't slap him first!
This is not fair!
I'm coming after you!
It's okay, it's okay.
This guy, this is my next target.
I'm getting targeted!
I'm naturally getting targeted!
This is not fair!
That's right.
Yeah, that's right.
You saw me there, didn't you?
Oh my god.
It's the pineapple!
I'm not gonna make it!
The pineapple!
Penguin hates me!
I...
Okay, it's okay.
I made it.
I made it across.
You goddamn penguin.
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it, guys.
I think I'm...
Why?
Dad, why?
Why did you have to save me?
Why did you have to slap me?
Oh, no.
No, please.
I'm not the last one.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Yes!
No!
I hate you!
I hate you so much!
I hate
you so much!
They took it from me!
Oh, no!
Who the heck?
Who the heck was the 8th person?
Who the...
Who the heck is the 8th person?
Right at the end.
This is not fair.
This is...
I don't understand.
I was doing so well.
Oh, my God.
I didn't know what the penguin...
I don't know what it is.
But I get very...
Guys, I don't know if you know this, but I get very competitive.
I get very...
What a tarnation.
This is so...
This is so bull penguin.
That they knocked me out on the last second.
This should be legal.
There should be penguin police that I can call.
This should be absolutely bonkers.
I should be able to call the penguin cops on these.
Anyone get the license plates on those penguins?
Did anyone get the license plate on those penguins?
Those goddamn penguins!
Oh my god!
Okay, you're fine, Doki.
You're fine.
Unlicensed penguins.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine little Timmy playing with his Oshie Doki and being called a penguin for going faster.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I am family friendly.
Anyway, as you guys can see, the more you attack people, the faster you get.
I don't understand.
Why can they slap me?
I'm the streamer here.
Why are they slapping me?
But yes, so if you get your slap correctly, you can basically slap again.
So the whole instance is you gotta keep slapping.
So the more slaps you do, the faster you go.
Like, how dare they slap me.
What happened to streamer privileges?
Exactly.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, let's look at the season pass.
Oh my god, you can have a molten skateboard?
I guess you can grind out...
I guess they were...
They already grinded the penguin points that much?
Oh my god.
Hey guys.
Oh, new map.
I remember you.
No.
Get away.
Get those glasses away.
Stop looking at me.
Get away.
I will slap you.
Get away from me.
That's right.
Leave.
Yeah.
Oh!
What are you doing?
You're pineapple behind.
That's right.
What are you doing?
Are you even a penguin?
That's right.
Slap.
What?
Desktop A3W18L.
Bro, this guy This guy just connected his desktop name into into the account.
Hey guys.
How much have you guys been grinding?
The game just came out yesterday.
How do you guys have cosmetics already?
That's not fair.
Most default user.
He's playing from his work computer.
It literally came out at 8pm yesterday.
How do you guys have all pineapples?
That's right.
Yeah.
What?
I didn't say it.
You penguin.
You god damn penguin.
Oh.
No.
I missed.
He didn't miss.
Never miss on your slaps guys.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know about the slap mechanic.
That's right.
No.
I missed.
I have to get away.
You don't know about the slap mechanic too.
I'm going to take advantage of...
That's right.
My slap now.
Oh.
I see you dragon.
I see you.
I'm coming for you.
Yeah.
Wait.
Where's my...
Oh.
They stole all my sardines.
Where's my sardines?
Oh no.
That's right.
Oh.
I'm coming for you.
No.
You...
Use the whale.
You cheaters.
Don't slap me.
But what if I slap you instead?
Alright.
Get over here.
Haha.
That's right.
Use your whale too early.
Now it's my turn.
I'm coming in hot.
Oh.
Wait.
Nice.
Haha.
Fifth place.
Let's go.
That's right.
Fifth place.
Haha.
Look at those penguins.
I couldn't make it.
Look at them.
What losers.
Nice.
Yeah.
Wait.
Guys.
Do you guys see me?
I'm over here.
Guys.
Please.
Do you guys see me?
I'm over here.
Guys.
Do you guys see me?
Over there?
It's okay.
You'll see me at the end.
Some say fifth place is the real first place.
Yeah.
Guys.
As a person who's been played...
whose game is the second game chat.
This is literally like first place for me.
How did they do that tech?
How did they go so far?
I don't... They must have slapped somebody before.
Oh my god.
That's so smart.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
I did it.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh.
I did it.
I figured out the tech.
I'm so smart.
I figured it out.
I knew it.
I knew there was a tech to this.
I was like, there has to be...
The way they did that, there had to be a tech for it.
I knew it.
Some say I'm just a gamer.
Wait.
What?
How did they get that?
Okay.
No, I missed.
Oh, that's okay.
I won't miss the next...
I won't miss the next one though.
Got them.
You stupid penguins.
Come on.
Get closer.
Desktop.
A375.
Yes.
Alright.
Nice.
We're good.
Everything is okay.
I lost all my sardines.
This was a hidden... Oh, I stole all his sardines.
Never mind.
JK.
Didn't lose any more sardines.
Get out of the way.
Move, penguin.
Get out the way.
That's alright.
We made it.
That's right.
Look at these penguins that couldn't make it.
Oh.
Sucks to be you.
My sardines.
Thank God.
That's right.
Hey, guys.
Hey.
That's me.
Oh.
Hey, guys.
Get out.
I need them to see me.
Everybody keeps blocking me.
Everybody.
That's right.
Stand in front of me, guys.
I know the movement tech.
Where's the countdown?
Set.
Yeah.
That's right.
Oh, I'm coming for you.
Yeah.
I came for you.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Let's get it.
We're okay.
We just can't have people.
What?
Okay.
It's fine.
Desktop.
The guy that's on their work computer.
That's okay.
It's just a little ahead of me.
But that's okay.
We got this.
Oh, that's a seven.
I keep thinking that's a one.
And I was like, how did I lose all my sardines?
Yes.
Okay.
How did I smack a whale?
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
No.
You guys keep stealing all of the goddamn sardines.
Okay.
Nice.
That's right.
You guys used a whale at the wrong time.
Because now it's my turn.
Get out.
You know it's penguin.
It's my penguin hour.
Alright.
Oh, hey.
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
No.
Into the tunnel I go.
I missed.
No.
We didn't miss though.
Oh, come on.
Yes.
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
It's okay.
We can still make it.
We can still make it, guys.
We're fine.
That's right.
Look who couldn't make it.
I see you there.
Couldn't make it.
Wait.
Guys, I got eighth.
Where am I?
Guys, look at me.
Yay!
That's me.
Guys, everybody keeps Everybody keeps covering me up.
Alright.
The final activity.
That's right.
Stand in front of me, everybody.
Stand in front of me, guys.
Dragoon, form a wall right now.
That's right.
Form a wall.
Yeah.
So easy.
Oh, no.
Not like that.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh, no.
No.
Okay.
We're okay.
In the air?
That should be legal.
Oh, no.
Come on.
Slap him.
I need a slap.
Guys, please.
Just one slap.
Leave some sardines for everybody else.
No.
Oh, I missed a crab.
Okay.
Please.
Everybody.
I can't touch anybody.
I can't slap anyone.
Nobody is allowing me to slap.
Oh, yes.
Oh, I got the last slap.
The last minute slap for the ages.
Oh, I don't think we're gonna make it, guys.
I don't think we're gonna make it.
Everybody is...
No, I don't even...
No.
Wait, wait, wait.
Eight, nine, ten.
No!
I can't!
I can't ever make the final race.
I can't.
I can't...
Oh, I can slap the pink guys.
Why can't I never make the finals?
It's not fair.
I can't even join in.
I can't.
I hope Guilty has a very nice day.
And that he gets everything he ever wants in life.
And that when he goes to sleep, he wakes up the next morning.
Thanks for making me laugh, Guilty.
Of course, MonsterMV, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm happy to brighten your day up.
I hope everybody has a wonderful time.
And enjoys their day.
What do you mean that's toxic?
I'm literally wishing him a nice day.
Oh, I can put on...
I can have glasses.
I can have glasses on now.
It's over.
I have glasses now.
Now I can actually see.
I hope he wakes up.
This is a threat.
It's not a threat.
I'm not threatening anybody.
I'm just wishing him to have a great, wonderful time.
God, you can have a guitar.
Wait, that's so cool.
What are the...
Wait, can I claim this?
Oh, this is the next one.
Okay, I have...
Oh, there's a guitar.
What's this?
Oh, what?
I can like...
I can like fire bend.
Wait, that's sweet.
I can be gold.
Wait, I want to be gold?
Wait, I...
What is this?
I like how there's like penguins dancing in the background when you're looking through the...
When you're looking through the season pass.
Alright, I'm gonna go grab some water real quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
How
the heck do you guys have pineapples?
Isn't that expensive?
How long have you been playing, Mehdi?
How long have you been playing the game?
Like, how do you have this?
We farmed a lot.
Like, I'm like, the game came out yesterday night!
How do you have a pineapple?
I am a play tester.
These, like, the Japanese penguins are just like, what's going on?
The Japanese penguins are just looking at us and like, what's going on?
What's going on in the corner?
Alright, guys.
Dragoons, form a wall!
Oh my god, the Japanese penguin has like, it's like an ice cream!
Alright, Dragoons, form a wall!
You know what time it is!
It's for me to grab Alright.
You guys, guys, you have to wait for me, guys.
You guys failed the one thing.
You guys have to wait for me.
There you go.
Yeah!
Okay, come on.
No!
Not yet!
No, I missed.
Oh, no, I missed.
That's right.
Oh, I'm coming for you.
I'm coming for you.
That's right.
There we go.
Oh, wait, what?
What did I hit?
Somebody has been defeated?
You can die?
Like, what?
What do you mean they've been defeated?
I didn't realize they can actually lose.
Alright.
Who bumped me in the last second?
Alright, don't worry.
We're still okay.
This is like race number one.
Race number one is like the easiest.
If you like can't even get through race number one, maybe you're just not meant to be a racer.
You're just not meant to drive a penguin.
Alright, come on, please.
I just need two.
Guys, can you guys get closer?
Guys, please.
That's right.
Whoever bumped me, it's over for you.
Get out of here.
Whoever bumped me, it's...
Oh, thank god we still made it.
Oh, we still made it.
That was close.
Thank god I got the well inside.
I could've said all that and actually got eliminated.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, we're fine.
I did not get eliminated.
I actually could've got eliminated.
I said all that.
But I didn't.
Of course the ice cream penguin gets it.
Like, you can tell he grinded that cosmetic for so long.
That would... Yeah, but it didn't happen, guys.
Guys, form a wall for real this time.
Guys, form a wall and don't go until I slapped you.
Okay?
Dragoons.
Form a... We must defeat the ice cream.
We must defeat the ice cream penguin.
That is our only hope.
Thank you.
Good dragoons listen to order.
Yeah, that's right.
My sardine.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, we're gonna grab another sardine.
I feel like I could never get sardines at all.
Like, everybody just keeps stealing sardines from me.
Oh, okay.
I didn't want to get slapped.
I needed my personal space.
No!
Okay, everything's okay.
No need to panic, Doki.
We're all friends here.
That's right.
Get out.
It's whale hour.
That's right.
Oh my gosh.
I thought I was gonna miss.
Oh, and then... I defeated somebody.
Wait!
Get out of my game!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, come on.
Stop!
Please!
You know what my skin is!
You know that!
Stop!
Please!
Please stop!
Okay.
We're okay.
People are just...
No, no, no!
We're okay.
We just made it!
That's right!
Yeah!
You didn't make it!
Yeah, that's right!
Yeah!
Party!
Get out of here!
That's right.
Whoa!
What skin is that?
What?
That's a mecha paint!
How did you become a mecha penguin?
All right, guys.
Get in front of me!
Dragoons!
We're still in it!
Form a wall!
We have to defeat the ice cream...
The ice cream!
Form a wall!
All right, there we go.
Yeah, there we go.
Watch you.
Oh, no!
Guys, we're working together so that I can win.
Like...
Guys!
We're working together so I can win.
Right, guys?
There we go.
Are you serious?
That's so bull penguin!
That's right.
I'm going to beat you up because I'm angry now.
I'm going to vent my frustrations onto you as a penguin.
All right, there we go.
Oh, I'm coming in for you.
Okay, that was pretty sick.
Oh, I can grab sardines as a whale!
Uh-uh.
All right, get out.
Get out.
All right.
See, guys?
I told you I'm PG.
Wait!
Oh!
Where am I?
That's right!
Penguins are meant to fly!
Oh, I don't know... No!
That's right!
Penguins are so meant to fly!
I'm still correct, though.
I'm still correct in my statement.
I...
No matter what, I'm still correct in what I say.
No, are you serious?
Okay.
Oh, no.
Nice.
No!
How did I get in front of me?
Fist!
It's fine.
It's like the highest we've ever been.
We were so close!
We were so close, but we made it to the finals!
We made it to the finals.
Guys, guys, these guys...
Get off your whale!
How did you have your whale out?
Put your whale back in!
All right, guys.
Dragons!
I can see you guys are still here!
Stand in front of me, dragons!
We must defeat Ice Cream Penguin!
And by we, I mean I.
Dragons!
That's right.
There you go.
Good dragons follow orders.
Remember that.
No!
How did I miss?
Please!
What happened, dragons?
I thought we were in this together!
Stop!
Guys, we have to work together!
What?
There's bombs!
Since when were there bombs?
That's messed up.
That's so messed up!
You stupid penguin!
You dumb, dumb penguin!
I bet...
I bet other penguins don't like you.
That's the best I can do.
To make sure I don't insult anybody.
I bet other penguins...
I bet penguin bombs don't even like you.
That's right.
I said it.
I goddamn said it.
That's right.
Oh my god, please.
No!
Please!
Get him!
Yes!
Nice!
That's right!
I made it!
I'm done!
Damn, too far.
We did it!
We got in the finals!
What the heck?
What is that cosmetic?
That's actually so badass.
Where am I?
Oh, there I am!
You see me?
I'm blowing the bubbles!
Wait, I'm eighth!
I'm eighth!
That's right.
Look at me.
I'm blowing the bubbles.
That's me.
Hello.
Oh my god, I'm gaming.
We'll do one more public matchmaking and then we'll do custom lobbies.
Nice.
Yeah!
Oh my god, I'm in pineapple!
Wait, I'm novice now!
Did I rank up?
I'm gaming.
See, in my third race I already made it to the finals.
Wait, I can be a pineapple.
Guys, to represent dragoons you all have to be the pineapple.
Guys.
Guys, to let me know you're a dragoon you gotta be a pineapple.
Them's the rules.
Alright.
Now I can finally look at the...
Is it in the season pass?
Like, what is that?
There's a volcano.
Oh my god, you can be a god?
You can be a little god.
Okay.
I saw someone with this.
That's a cool penguin.
Oh, I want this!
Wait.
I really want this.
This one's so cute.
It's like a little ukulele.
What about...
Oh, and then there's like...
Hula.
Hula penguin.
And then there's another goddess penguin.
That's level 31.
It can't be that difficult.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Now that I know which one's a dragoon.
Now that I know everybody.
Now that I know.
If none of the pineapples make a wall for me in this race.
I will know who you are and what your name is.
If you don't make...
If you don't make a wall.
Can I see a pineapple?
That is not a wall.
I will know.
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
I forgot to adjust the volume.
Sorry.
I got...
I got too invested in the penguins.
Oh, no.
I can't...
I can't change the... Okay.
It's too late.
We'll change the volume in the private.
Sorry.
I've been having too much fun.
I forgot to change the volume.
Wait.
Sorry.
Oh, they're slapping it.
There's a lot of slapping to the volume.
What's wrong with that?
This is a slappy slap world here.
Alright, guys.
Pineapples.
Pour me pineapple wall.
Good dragoons fall over.
I know you're a pineapple now.
Sir, what are you guys doing?
What are your other pineapples doing?
Pineapple wall!
You get no excuse.
You have no excuse if you don't form a pineapple wall.
I literally can see you.
I can see you're not forming a wall.
That's right.
Get over here, dragoons.
I need a slap.
Build that wall.
I need the slap wall.
Penguins aren't meant to be able to fly.
Get down here.
Oh, they're not pineapples.
You are a pineapple!
What are you doing?
I am the main pineapple.
I am OG pineapple.
Stop!
I am the pineapple leader.
You can't slap the pineapple leader.
Okay, nice.
Okay, we just need one more.
We just literally need one more.
Get over here, you random guy.
JK, I don't need you.
I don't need anybody.
I got my whale.
There's like another...
You can get like a free floaty.
But like, I think the whale's cuter.
Not gonna lie.
I honestly... That's right.
Good dragoons let me slap.
That's right.
Get over here.
No, no, no.
No, don't get over here.
That's right.
Get over here.
No!
Are you serious?
Oh, please.
Please.
Oh, we're still in.
We're still in.
Okay, nice.
Never failed the first round.
Alright.
Pineapples!
Why didn't all of you form a wall of pineapples?
What is your excuse?
Guys, guys, we can't let...
Guys, we can't let a non-pineapple win.
Guys.
Down with this penguin!
Good dragoons.
Let me slap.
Alright.
Pineapples!
Get in front!
All the pineapples get in front of me right now!
Form that wall!
That is not in...
Guys, that is not in front of me.
Guys, guys...
Guys,
please.
Please.
It was a very simple instructions.
I don't understand why we can't form a...
A horizontal line of pineapples.
I...
No!
It's okay.
I got the glider.
I'll fly over all of you.
They're doing a mosh pit.
It's alright.
I don't need you guys.
I'm in first place.
Whoever...
Did that thing where they tried to...
Sabotage me.
And kick me off.
That's right.
I bet you regret that now.
Don't you?
I bet you regret that.
Now I'm...
I got the paraglider because of it.
Oh no.
Okay.
We're in the final stretch.
Please.
I don't have any sardines.
Where are the sardines?
No, no, no.
Come on.
Pass me the sardines.
No!
Please!
Why are you taking my sardines?
I have nothing!
Oh my god.
You penguin.
You god damn penguin.
You...
I made it.
God damn fish.
You're not even a penguin.
You're a fish.
You're beneath me.
You're a god damn fish.
Fish get consumed.
They have the brain cell of a...
Of a rock.
Okay.
That's good.
We have a...
We have a pineapple to represent us.
A delicious pineapple.
You can't say that.
Alright.
Pineapples.
We'll do this.
We'll try this again.
Guys.
Pineapples.
Wall.
Pineapple.
I see you guys are not for me.
I give up.
Good dragoons just deserve to get slapped.
That's right.
I said it.
Your duty is just to get slapped, dragoons.
That's right.
This is a non-pineapple.
I'm going to get you.
I got your license plate.
I got your license plate, Mr. Yellow.
That's right.
I got it.
You penguin.
You fish.
You god damn...
Father loving fish.
I tried so hard.
I'm trying so hard to be PG.
This guy just really likes fish.
That's really it.
There's nothing else.
I'm the good person.
He just really loves fish.
I don't know.
Alright.
That's right.
You're going to regret this.
You're going to regret all of this.
That's...
No.
That's not fair.
That's actually not fair.
What?
How did I mess that up?
It's not fair.
Please.
I just need... I need...
Hang in there.
I'm hanging in.
Oh.
What do you mean?
People are already placing.
No.
Don't get out.
Get out.
Please.
Oh.
I made it.
Nice.
That's it.
You fishes.
That's right.
Pineapples.
We're slowly eliminating the non-pineapples.
Let's go.
Get rid of all the pineapples.
Pineapple supreme.
Not even close.
You mother fishes.
Alright.
There you go.
No.
I got fishes.
Okay.
I got...
I got the slaps in time.
I got it in time.
Please don't slap me.
Please.
No.
We have to work together.
We're pineapple together strong.
Please pineapple together.
Yeah.
That's right.
I can slap though.
Pineapple together strong guys.
Remember that.
We have to work together against the non-pineapples.
Let's go.
Guys.
Remember we are friends.
We are pineapple friends.
Pineapple strong.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Got you.
I got you.
I see you.
Come on.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
3, 4, 5.
I made it.
Nice goal.
We made it to the final race.
We've always made it to the final race.
That's right!
We always...
We always made it to the race.
At the very end.
Because we're gamers.
Gamers.
I'm in.
Let's go!
That's right!
Pineapple Sweep!
Let's go!
Wait, I don't even...
Wait, I don't think they're even part of the crew.
I think they just...
I don't know.
Are they part of the crew?
I can't tell.
What if they're in their own crew?
Like...
I'm like...
Wait, I don't know.
I don't know if this guy is...
This guy is part of the pineapple crew.
I knew it.
Oh my god.
The pineapple reigns supreme.
Nice.
Yay!
I ranked up!
Goodbye, peasants.
Hahaha.
Talk to me when you...
Talk to me when...
When...
I can be...
Guys, okay.
To be...
To be a dragon.
To represent the dragons.
We all have to be...
Red pineapples.
That's like...
Wait, I can change the color?
Oh, I can!
Wait, that's so cute!
Wait, I want this color.
I want this color.
Alright.
To represent the dragons...
You gotta be a red...
The red is like...
The color of winners.
And then a pineapple.
Alright.
It's like a tomato, exactly.
It's like a tomato within a...
Within a pineapple.
So like, that is how...
That's how we know that you're a dragon.
Oh my god, I can change it!
I wanna be blue!
Alright, wait, I wanna...
Okay, let's...
Let's fix the volume.
I keep forgetting to...
Sound guy, is there anything I need to fix?
Or is everything good?
Just kinda bring down...
And music bring up...
And bring up overall.
Is there anything I have to fix, sound guy?
The music...
I like how...
It's always...
It's always Doug that's like, please...
Turn down the music.
It's always him...
That's trying to turn down...
I'm gonna turn it up now.
I'm gonna turn...
Please...
Alright...
Alright, guys, we'll do one more public match.
Cause I wanna see how many dragoons are in the lobby.
Alright, guys...
Alright, guys, remember...
Red penguin with pineapple suit.
Guys...
Guys, remember...
Red penguin in a pineapple suit.
What other skins do they have?
Alright...
Let's see...
Okay, we got here.
Wait, how...
How do they get the...
The other...
Okay, money, money, money...
Wait, how do they get the other penguin?
You saw that other...
Wait, was it from the shop?
Does the shop rotate?
Wait, I think...
I really like the burger penguin.
How do they get the...
Oh, it's an achievement?
Oh, maybe it's an achievement.
Alright, how many?
Wait...
Oh, okay, I was like...
I was like, wait a minute.
Alright, guys, alright.
Alright, the red penguin...
Okay, you guys just haven't locked the red penguin yet.
I see.
Alright, that's good.
That's fine.
Alright, we have our dragoon army.
We will take over this lobby.
We will...
Get rid of all these normie penguins out of here.
This is pineapple land.
That's right.
Whoops, goodbye.
Slap to commemorate our time here.
Remember who you are, dragoons.
Long live the pineapple.
We
will reign supreme in pineapple land.
This is pineapple territory.
Slap.
We welcome each other, guys.
We welcome each other by slapping.
This is the pineapple way.
Slap the homies.
Alright, nice.
That's right.
There's way too many non-pineapples.
We gotta make sure they lose the race.
We gotta make sure they can't win.
Only the pineapple shall win.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Sorry, it's for the greater good.
I need to use you to win.
Whoa, wait, this is a new map.
Wait, the cloud's pretty cool.
It's for the greater good.
Mother pineapples, I need to slap you so I can be in the lead.
Alright, thank you.
I don't think that was intentional.
He just landed next to me.
It's alright.
No, I missed!
No!
No, I missed.
I'm not gonna get that now.
Guys, please.
Yes, thank you.
I think I slapped the majority of the penguins I slapped have been the pineapple penguins.
Like, it wasn't even intentional.
They just, all of them were just in front of me.
They were all just in front of me.
Oh, Kira.
You're next, Kira.
You're next.
I'm coming to get ya.
No!
Guys!
Slow down!
Please.
Please!
Okay, guys, I think this might be the first race I don't make it.
Guys, remember me.
Remember me.
Haha, JK.
No!
Wait, I think I'm gonna, I think I'm gonna make it!
I think, guys, guys, please, please, please!
No, there's no way!
No!
Wait, no, I still made it!
You can't block me!
No!
Remember me!
Get back here!
I'm leaving.
I can't...
I can't believe it.
I can't teach.
So messed up.
I can't show.
Only a non-gamer would win the burn series.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry, my monitor was turned off, guys.
I was going by pure sound alone.
Hey, guys, I don't know if you noticed, but I was going by pure sound.
So, like, what happened?
Oh my god.
Is that not me?
That's unfortunate.
Oh my god.
You see, this is why you shouldn't be too overconfident.
Because I was going by pure... I had my monitor turned off, guys.
So, you know, it's just so unlucky.
It's just so unlucky that my monitor was off.
I wonder what achievement you can get for clothes.
Oh, wait, what?
Reach season rank ace?
Oh, I guess these are like the competitive rewards.
That's pretty cool.
How did they get that?
Maybe that was from like beta testers.
Oh, wait, what?
Achieve first place in a tour?
Guys, does private lobbies count?
You can actually still play if you dropped out.
It's not just spectating.
No, that's fine.
If I'm dropped out, this lobby does not deserve my prize.
The lobby just didn't deserve me.
It's called self-care.
The lobby didn't deserve me.
Damn facts.
Okay.
Care for yourself.
Treat yourself.
Know your place.
Guys, what happened to the...
Guys, are all my dragoons in the other lobby still?
Guys, what happened?
No!
Dragoons!
Okay, no.
You're not red.
Why aren't you red?
You can't just say that.
You can't ask them why they're not red.
Guys, I told you guys.
You have to be red to be part of...
to enlist in the dragoon army.
You gotta be red, guys.
Alright, sorry.
We'll do...
I can't help it.
I really like...
The matchmaking has been really fun.
Custom lobbies after this.
For real.
Custom lobby after this.
Sorry.
After this.
Alright.
Guys, there's not a lot of us.
Guys, so we have to make do.
We will still convert this lobby into pineapples.
Okay.
There's...
Oh, no.
I just slapped him for fun.
No!
No, I messed up!
No, please, please!
I messed up!
I slapped too early!
I got too overzealous!
I got so overzealous!
I was like, Slap!
I saw another pineapple and I couldn't help it!
Not last anymore!
Who said that?
Which penguin?
Which penguin said that?
Turkey, why did you say penguin like that?
I'm just saying penguin.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Nice.
Okay, we got it.
We obtained a 250.
Nice.
Guys, what's wrong with DG Gaming?
Isn't that somebody's monitor?
Okay.
We're fine.
Things are still looking good.
Things are still looking good for Doki.
For Doki.
Doki bird.
Doki penguin.
Okay.
Let's get over here.
That's right.
You should've got the... should've got the...
Well, you should've got...
TG Gamer Pro.
Oh, I'm second!
Let's go.
It's that penguin.
Goddamn mother fish loving penguin right there.
Not like us pineapples.
Yeah!
Wait!
That's me!
Guys!
That's me up there.
Oh my god.
If you close your eyes, if you look down and don't see the name, it's technically me.
It's technically me.
That's me!
Oh, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Slap time.
No!
I missed the...
What?
Guys, what happened?
Guys, what happened to standing in front of me so I can also be part of the crew?
Like...
What happened?
I thought we were a team, guys.
Guys, guys, there's not a lot of us.
Guys, guys, there's not a lot of other pineapple penguins, guys.
We gotta work together.
Pineapples together strong, guys.
Remember, pineapple together strong.
We have to...
We don't work together.
What will we have?
Nothing.
We'll have nothing.
The non-pineapples will win.
And you don't want that.
That's right.
Nice.
No!
Not nice!
That's right.
Nice.
Alright, we're good.
We're good.
And I got the whale, too.
I got the whale at the end.
We're so good right now.
We're so good.
That's right.
Oh, we're up there.
We're up there.
It feels like you can, like, catch up.
What?
Where did these guys come from?
Where did those people behind me come from?
It feels like even though you can be last, you can catch up really, like, easily.
We're still here.
That's right.
Who can't make it?
Look at you.
Look at you, bros.
That's right.
Should have enlisted to the dragoon army.
Another pineapple!
That's me!
But what if she's red?
That's me, guys!
That's me!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
That's also me!
Alright, guys.
Guys, we weren't able to, like, form a pineapple.
How many non-pineapples are still in the lobby?
We gotta get rid of them.
We gotta make sure they don't make it to the finals.
We have to make it all pineapple.
No!
Guys!
Guys, wait up!
Guys, please!
We have to make sure all the, all the pineapples make it together, guys!
We gotta make sure that it's all pineapple.
How was I supposed to know that was gonna happen, chat?
Like, that was so full penguin!
That was actually so messed up.
It was so fished up, guys.
You don't understand.
That was the most fished thing I've ever seen.
That's so messed up.
I'm missing all the sardine!
It's not even worth it!
There's so many sardines!
There's so many sardines there!
No!
I got confused!
It confused me!
I'm so sad!
Guys, please!
Have mercy!
I need some sardines!
Please!
Oh, no!
The final stretch!
No!
Yes!
Okay!
I can slap this one!
Yes!
Okay!
I can slap another one!
But I don't need to!
I'll just do this!
Oh, I made it!
I made it!
Pineapples!
My brethren!
Who's this guy?
Get him out!
Who are these non-pineapples?
What a combat!
That's a non-pineapple!
How did you guys let this happen?
How did you let Draegen take this?
Get him out!
He has a target on his back!
If you see a penguin with green hair, get him out of here!
What a recovery!
Alright!
We need to make sure this guy has nothing in his life after this!
But, like, in-game!
In-game, guys!
In-game!
Guys, please!
Guys, why do they keep doing this to me?
Why?
Why do they keep doing this to me?
This is not fair!
Azzy, please let me slap you!
I swear to God, please!
Let me not hang in there!
Bro, that's so...
That's so messed up!
Hang in there!
Let me...
You got this, turkey!
Just hang in there!
Just...
No!
Just hang in there!
That's right.
Remember who you...
Remember turkey?
This was her in high school.
Now look at her.
As she bumps into everything.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Okay, I got it.
That's fine.
I got it.
We're okay.
I think it's only Tommy in first.
No!
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's first place.
That's all that matters, guys.
That's all that matters.
Please, please.
No, I missed!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Yes, guys, guys!
Yes!
Oh my God!
Nice!
I made it!
Wait!
No, that's... No, they're pineapples!
No!
I fell...
It's okay.
We got it, fellow dragon.
We got it.
Two out of three.
That's alright.
Good job on your computer.
Get this drinkin' out of here.
Let's get two out of three.
Two out of three.
I'll take those.
Alright.
Custom lobby for real now.
I'm sorry.
I got too invested in the rank system.
I think this game has been pretty fun.
Not gonna lie.
This game.
For those who don't know, the points builds up into how many points you get in your ranking.
Obviously, you guys saw Novice, Ordinary, Best in the Village, Pro, Top Notch, A-Star.
That's obviously the rank mode.
The more points you get, the higher ranking you are.
I'm Ordinary rank right now.
Ordinary rank.
So I got two of these medals and that adds up the totals too.
The medals give you more ranking power too.
The more medals you get, the higher rank you get.
Are you grinding?
I'm just ordinary.
I'm just an ordinary penguin.
Also, they're gonna add more courses in the future.
There's a lot of courses so far too.
Alright.
For real guys.
For real.
We're gonna...
We're gonna have private lobbies this time.
Alright.
Create room.
Alright guys.
Guys, you guys all have to put on the pineapple though.
Alright, this is the...
This is the lobby code.
I'll copy it too.
I think the fact that it's like a battle royale system makes it fun.
How the fuck are you pro?
I mean how?
Sorry.
How the fish are you pro?
That like surprised me.
I was like...
Do I have 40?
I can't tell.
I got started.
You guys got me.
Are you pro?
Okay.
How the flip did you get it?
It got me off guard.
Alright, nice.
You're happy cat?
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Guys, let's all have pineapples later on.
I wanna have a full pineapple lobby.
I love it, bud.
Slap.
Give your pen bro a slap for good luck, everybody.
To commemorate our first private lobby, we all have to slap each other.
Good job.
Guys, remember this is free to play.
So you can download the game right now to join the private lobbies, guys.
The custom lobbies.
You can literally download the game right now.
It's free to play.
The link is in my description and pinned.
Pinned in chat.
Slap, slap, slap.
Everybody gets free slaps.
Slap, slap.
This is how we say hello in penguin country.
How's the volume anyway?
I hope it's not too loud.
I hope the slapping is not too loud.
I hope it's not too overpowering.
Alright.
It slaps louder.
The slaps need to be louder.
It definitely needs to be louder.
I messed up guys!
Please!
This is my private lobby!
NYS, get out of here!
torn sound I keep messing it up!
It's okay.
We can recover.
I believe.
Nice that I needed that.
I got the paraglider.
I'm out of my groove!
I got the paraglider! Please.
Please, I'm just a little guy.
Oh my god!
He was a dragon!
The guy that got second earlier!
In our other lobby, in the public lobby.
Oh my god, please, guys.
Please, I'm literally the... guys, I'm literally the lobby leader.
You can't let me get knocked down, guys.
You can't knock me out.
I'm the lobby leader.
I have to be part of the lobby!
Because I don't want to be affecting you guys!
I want to play the game.
Why are you taking all the 13?
It's fine.
Get out of the way.
That's right.
Oh, I made it.
Oh, thank god.
I made it.
That's right.
I'm in it to win it.
Let's go.
Knock her out.
Alright, nice.
Nice.
Pineapple Supreme.
Pineapple Ruppers.
I can't even see us.
Where are we?
Where are...
Where am I?
I can't even see me.
Guys, guys, guys.
Stand in front, guys.
This is my lobby, everybody.
Guys, guys, I need you.
Guys, please.
I'm gonna slap you in...
Guys, it says ready, set, go.
Please!
How did you...
Why won't you let me slap you in game?
You let me slap you before ready, set, go.
This is illegal.
All my dragos won't let me slap them when we're in game.
This is messed up.
Oh, my god.
Are you serious?
The paraglider comes in right...
Guys, please.
Please, I'm so behind.
Guys, please don't make me spectator.
This is literally my own lobby.
I'm literally sponsored, guys.
Please.
Please let me play this game.
Oh, my god.
Please, come on.
Come on.
You're so close.
You're slapping range.
You're literally...
You're literally slapping range.
I see you slapping range.
That's... That's right.
That's...
I don't need to slap you.
I'll just be a whale.
Get out.
That's right.
Now I'm so close to...
What?
How did I not slap?
That shit means...
Are you serious?
I'm so unlucky.
Am I actually?
I'm sad.
It's fine.
We're gonna still make it.
Yes.
I did it.
26 times.
Who didn't make it?
Who didn't?
Yeah, I see you.
That's right.
I see you.
I still made it.
I'm still gaming.
I wish we're Empire.
That's right.
We're still in it.
We're still in it to win it.
You guys all tried so hard to get me out.
But it's too late.
I'm still here.
That's right.
You can't get me out of it.
Get slapped.
Oh my God.
We are...
Oh no.
I really want that though.
I really want...
That was like a magic carpet filled with sardines.
That was literally a magic carpet filled with...
No.
Oh my God.
That's okay.
That's good.
That's...
No.
You penguin.
Goddamn penguin.
Oh no.
Come on.
Yes.
Yeah.
All right.
We're still in it.
Okay.
80%.
We have ultimate.
We can keep going.
All right.
That's all right.
Let's go.
It's fast.
Speed.
And I can slap him here too.
The final stretch.
Oh my God.
They're all so close.
Are you serious?
Oh.
Okay.
The final stretch.
Two.
Two sardines.
Oh.
This is a new map.
This has to be a new map because I don't know this map.
I've never seen this map before in my life.
Come on.
I don't have it.
Let
me in.
Let me in.
Please.
Please let me in, my
man.
Stop.
Please.
Let me on the carpet.
I'm like just running at the carpet.
Oh my God.
I'm a ghost.
No.
This is unfair.
Don't ever know.
That's the point.
Let's go.
I don't want to race.
I'm banished to the spectator realm.
What's the point?
I'm literally dead.
The god damn sand level.
All my homies hate sand.
I think all the maps were pretty fun, not gonna lie.
All the maps are really unique in its own way, so...
I don't really have a favorite so far.
I have a non-favorite, the sand one.
I know which map I hate.
But anyway, all the other maps are great.
All the other maps are great.
Except for the sand one.
Wait, you can slap as a sand?
Wait, are you saying I can sabotage people?
Oh my god.
Wait, you should have said that in the beginning.
It's always...
Okay, nice.
Pineapple sweet, let's go.
That's all that matters.
Let's go, guys.
Yeah!
Pineapple sweet!
Let's go!
That's fine.
The pineapple sweet, though.
The pineapple sweet.
The tomato and the pineapple suit.
In the end...
In the end, that's all that matters.
All right, I'm gonna reset the lobby, guys.
So we can have new people in.
Okay, lobby's gonna be reset soon.
All right, select play mode.
All right, create room.
Boom, boom, boom.
All right.
Copy.
I'm gonna copy this.
All right, now.
Join up.
Join up, goons.
It's your time to shine.
Remember, this is a free-to-play game, so anybody can join.
Anybody can play with us.
What?
How are you all max?
How are...
How are your pros?
The game came out yesterday.
Like, what were you...
Guys, remember to click on my link and download the game.
All right, we have one more spot.
If I can't race, no one can reset the lobby.
No!
Why didn't you tell them my plan?
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My plan!
Oh, my God.
I can't believe you guys got...
You guys figured out my plan.
How did you guys figure it out?
Wait, did the site crash?
Oh, my God.
Did we crash the website?
That's good.
You made it like that.
Show them the power of the dragons.
By the way, you can download it on Steam, by the way, guys.
You can...
You downloaded the game on Steam.
It's literally on Steam for free.
Yay!
I'm flying.
Two dragoons together strong.
Guys, let's try and get all pineapples.
If you have pineapple unlocked, grab that pineapple suit on.
All right, here we go.
Mangrove jungle.
I should enjoy this map.
This map's fun.
All right.
We got this.
All right, guys.
Blow bubbles.
Just show them what we got.
Are you serious?
How...
There were so many of you guys.
How did not a single one of you guys got slapped?
I don't understand.
There were so many of you guys in front of me.
How did none of you guys got hit?
How is that...
Oh, nice.
I got it.
Nice.
Complaining works.
Guys.
Yay.
Complaining works.
Let's go.
I can go.
I knew it.
If you complain hard enough, you'll eventually get what you want.
Oh, my god.
How am I stuck?
How am I...
Please.
I haven't got a single hit.
Oh, there you go.
Deserved.
I'll remember what you did.
Matt, can we get over here?
How do we get over here?
Please, please don't do this to me.
All right.
Nice.
We're fine.
Get hit.
All right.
There we go.
We're okay.
I mean like there's no way.
There's no way we're like, we can't make it to top 32 guys.
Like there has to be like, look, there's no way.
We don't need to be up ahead guys.
There's no way.
We still have time.
Guys, we still have time.
Ah!
Shit!
Okay, that's 30 of them.
We made it.
Yeah!
Yay!
I told you guys, there's no way we don't make it.
I told you.
I told you there's no way.
There's no way we wouldn't make it.
I told you guys.
And I was right.
I was right.
All right.
Nice.
Slap.
Guys, please.
I need to get like, oh, thank God.
Okay.
I got one hit.
I think I know the plan.
I just have to be like in the pile.
I have to be in the pile.
In the dragoon pile.
I gotta be in the middle of the mosh pit.
I have to get a slap.
It's the mosh pit hour.
Come on.
Yes!
Got it.
Nice.
Wait, where did that come from?
But that's okay.
I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna complain.
I'm not- HAHA.
I have to be in the mosh pit.
Yeah... guys we gotta start moshing.
Okay.
Just gotta start moshing.
Okay, we're ahead.
We're ahead.
This is what winners feel like.
Okay.
This is- this is what third place feels like.
This is what third place feels like.
Okay, this is what fourth place... fifth place feels like, guys.
Fifth place is still okay.
Fifth place is still pretty alright, guys.
That's all I'm saying.
Alright, nice.
I'm going straight in.
Okay, not like...
Guys, there's... oh, please.
Alright, that's fine, that's fine.
That is also fine.
And then we're gonna grab...
We're so close to more sardines here.
Come on.
Jump!
That's right, mine!
No, no, I needed that sardine!
No!
Get over here!
Yes!
Get over here.
That's right, you don't deserve to live in game.
You deserve to live in real life.
I hope you wake up to have a great, wonderful day.
Oh, God, okay.
Nice, alright.
We're so in.
Yeah!
Party!
Who did that?
Did you do that?
Get out.
Can't you see?
Look at the people that didn't make it through the boat.
Goodbye.
Yeah, that's right.
I see you, Neil.
Didn't get your...
You didn't get your boat ticket.
Bought the wrong ticket.
Alright.
Marsh pit.
I hate this part.
This is the world...
The one with the...
You can miss the world thing.
Guys, marsh pit.
We're mashing.
Guys, we're mashing.
Come on.
We gotta mash.
Guys.
Guys!
What?
Did you not hear what I said?
I had one simple instruction.
I don't understand how we could mess that up.
How did we mess up the mash?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
We both got it.
They just...
But Doki, they were mashing.
You just weren't invited.
What do you mean?
I started the mash.
How could I not be invited if I started it?
Are you serious?
Who was it?
Come up to the front of the class right now.
Who did that?
Hey, that's fine.
This is not fine.
This is not fine anymore.
I am not feeling fine anymore.
Get over here.
I'm heading over.
No!
I was too fast.
It's too fast.
No!
LET MY WHEEL IN!
PLEASE!
LET MY WHEEL IN, AT LEAST!
NOOOOO!
I'M SORRY!
PLEASE LET ME IN!
PLEASE, I'M DOING THE CHORES!
PLEASE!
IT'S NOT FAIR!
Oh, you guys got sand land.
That's fine, nevermind.
That's fine with me.
I didn't want to do the sand level.
That's fine, I'm gonna slap you.
You think you'll be safe?
We're all gonna slap you.
That's right.
I'll make sure you're not gonna have- That's right, I'm gonna target you!
And I'm gonna target you!
That's right!
The ghosts are in the lead now, how is it?
And I'm gonna steal- Oh!
Okay, nevermind.
That's right.
Where are you?
I see you're a real penguin.
Get over here.
Get over here!
Oh, you're trying to run away?
Oh, you're trying to run away, you little- You little FISH!
That's right, get over here!
I'm coming after you!
God damn it!
No.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, Glocks, I'm gonna get you!
I'm gonna get you!
Oh, we don't even get- We don't even get certain games!
This is not fair!
Oh, I'll make sure you don't win.
I didn't mean to do that, but I wanted to slap him.
That's fished up.
I had to make sure- I had to make sure that he doesn't get to enjoy the game.
If I am a ghost...
Get over here.
Where are you?
No!
I couldn't hit it!
Oh, no.
Does that push me forward?
Nice.
Okay.
Get over here.
Yeah, that's right!
Oh, that's right!
Yeah!
Oh, you guys didn't make it?
Oh, that's so sad!
Oh, you didn't make it!
Hahaha!
It's alright.
Two out of three.
I take those.
You can't afford a pineapple!
If you're a red penguin, that means you are a pineapple!
Why aren't you a pineapple?
Look straight!
Why would penguins wear pineapple?
Why aren't you a pineapple?
You clearly- You clearly can't afford it!
Hahaha!
Don't think I'm stupid!
I know you have!
I know you have the pineapple!
Hahaha!
I know you have it!
Wait, what did I unlock?
Did I unlock something?
Wait, I unlocked something.
What was it?
Oh, it's the...
It's the name tag.
Yeah, sardine.
Actually, I like the whale.
I think the whale is really cute.
I don't want to be green.
He's adorable!
Alright.
That's not what I want.
Private time.
Hahaha!
Okay, private time!
Alright, another lobby.
Coffee.
I'm going to post it in the chat first.
And then reveal it on stream.
Alright, here you go.
Another private lobby.
Like I said, it's free to play.
So just download.
Click on the link.
I don't know if they fixed the link yet.
But click on the link and then you can join the game.
Join this lobby.
Alright.
Why don't you have a pineapple?
Well, now that I know how easy it is to get the pineapple.
Hahaha!
Well, I figured out it was so easy to get it.
Alright.
Alright, we have one more spot, guys.
We have one more.
There's 39.
Alright, guys.
39!
We have one more slot!
40!
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, I'm ready.
I hope you guys are all ready.
It'll suck if you guys aren't.
It'll be a little awkward if you guys aren't ready.
Guys.
Nice.
Alright.
Ba-ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum.
Nice.
Phantom dragon with no pineapple.
Laugh at this guy.
Little bubbles at him for not having a pineapple.
Look at him.
How do you not have a pineapple yet?
Hahaha!
Little bubbles at him for not having a pineapple.
That's right.
No pineapple, penguin.
Hahaha!
Let's slap him!
Slap him!
Turkey, stop pineapple-shaming.
I can't believe you don't have a pineapple, Phantom.
Where did he go?
Hahaha!
No pineapple.
That's right.
Anyway, this is my favorite costume.
Hahaha!
That I can afford.
For the...
For the affordable costumes, this one's my favorite.
But yeah, apparently the more you play, the more costumes you unlock.
Which makes sense.
Hahaha!
I wonder if that's how they got the... the... the costume where he looks like Darth Vader.
It's fast, penguin!
That's what it is.
Look at this.
This is a pineapple lobby.
Hahaha!
That's right.
This is a pineapple lobby right here.
Oh, God.
God, I missed the mosh pit again!
They all moshed without me!
Hahaha!
Guys, please!
I just wanna be included in the mosh pit!
Stop moshing without me!
It's not fair!
Hahaha!
I just wanna be included, guys!
That's right.
Get out.
This is my lobby.
Alright, here we go.
No, I'm not going.
Oh, no!
No, not the crab!
Who let this crab in here?
He doesn't even go here!
Please.
Please, I don't have any sardines.
I only have two.
I haven't been able to grab anything.
Please, I need to feed my hungry family.
My family of me.
No!
There's...
There's no way!
I think I'm last!
Oh, no.
This has to be the worst I've ever done.
Oh, my God.
Did I got slapped in the back?
Coyote, please!
Oh, thank God!
Nice, JK.
I'm not last anymore.
Look at these losers who are so slow.
Like, look at you guys.
Oh, my God.
How are you guys so slow?
Everybody has whales already.
I only have two sardines.
This is messed up.
I don't have enough.
I actually don't have enough.
I don't have enough right now.
Oh, he missed.
That's good.
Okay, nice.
I got that.
Three sardines.
That's three is more than two.
Four sardines.
Five sardines.
Seven sardines.
How did I get seven?
Oh, I made it.
That's right.
I made it.
Let's go.
You guys are just...
Who are the ones that don't make it?
Look at him.
The non-pineapples.
All right.
Okay.
Look at the non-pineapples.
Oh, they couldn't catch the fly.
Put it to my left, guys.
Look at these dragons that couldn't make it.
Look at these non-pineapples that couldn't make it to the play.
Mosh pit.
Guys, mosh pit.
Get in here.
Put me in the middle of the mosh pit, guys.
Guys, I need to mosh.
I need...
Guys, mosh that.
Get in here.
Yes!
I was in the middle!
That's all it took.
I did it, guys.
I moshed.
I finally moshed.
Okay, nice.
I'm at 10%.
And that's how you mosh, chat.
That's how... and she misses the second.
No!
Who was it?
I need... did anyone grab the license plate?
Did anyone grab the license plate of that penguin?
Give me their name so I can kick them out of my lobby.
Give me their... Oh, whoa.
Oh, four?
Okay, that was pretty good.
That was some pretty good jumping.
You did it yourself.
There's no way.
That's right.
Oh, you see me?
You know I'm fucking coming...
You know I'm fishing coming over for you.
You know that.
Come on.
You know that, Iggy.
I'm coming for you, Iggy.
That's right.
Get your penguin ass over here.
No!
It's fine.
That's fine.
We're... this is like second round.
We don't need to be first, guys.
It's literally second round.
We don't need to... We don't need to be first in the second round.
We can be 12.
We can be 12, guys.
It's fine.
Alright, laugh at the... Oh, no!
No, Pineapple's made it!
That's right, Coyote.
That's right.
Alright, guys.
Point at these... Point at these dragons, Coyote.
Make it to the boat, guys.
Go to the side and point at them and laugh.
Guys, go to the side.
Look at these... God, look at these losers.
Look at them.
I love how we're all on the side.
We're all on the side and pointing at them.
Coyote and me.
Guys, mosh pit.
Guys, I'm in the center.
Guys, mosh pit right now.
Stop!
Guys, we all know what to do in the mosh pit, guys.
Nice.
How did... Okay, we all blocked each other, but that's okay.
No!
God damn it.
Don't touch me.
Don't you dare touch me.
Personal space.
Nice.
Okay.
How did you get... You have 10?
Oh, you deserve that, actually.
You... You definitely deserve that.
Okay.
I don't know what I got here.
Oh, I don't want to grab the bomb, though.
Okay.
That's double.
Nice.
Okay.
No, I want that.
I want that.
No!
I missed!
I did the crook inside.
That's fine.
Missing is part of the progress.
It builds character.
Oh, God.
Okay, that's fine.
It builds character, guys.
It builds...
Guys, it builds character.
Okay.
Guys, we all...
Nice.
That's right.
This is what character growth does.
That's... Get out.
I've built enough character now.
All right.
Come on.
No!
Nice.
Okay.
Get over here.
Yeah, I'm coming for you, Medi.
That's right.
Medi, get over here.
Get over here.
Get over here!
Get o... Okay, I don't need you.
Still made it.
I don't need you.
I don't need you dead.
Yeah!
Look at... We... We eliminated more non-penguins!
Non... Non-pineapple!
All right.
Go to the side, guys.
Go to the side and point at these non-pineapples in the lab.
Point at them.
I couldn't make it.
Nice.
Every round, we got rid of more non-pineapples.
Okay.
There's only...
All right.
We're the majority.
Nice.
We have... We're the majority, guys.
That's good.
We got pineapple territory now.
That's all we wanted.
We're in pineapple land.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, what?
How did I miss?
I didn't even hit anything!
Why did it say I missed?
No, we can't let this... No!
No!
This is not fair!
How did I goddamn collapse?
Ragroll, please!
I want some sardines!
I need the feed!
Please!
I need to be fed!
Okay, you deserve that, actually.
For stealing all the sardines.
You actually deserve that.
You goddamn... Please!
Ragroll, get sardines!
That's right.
I'm coming for you, Ragroll.
Remember me.
That's right.
You try to take all my sardines.
I take your life in-game.
Oh.
We're so close to Morph.
Wait.
Okay.
We got this.
Yes!
We made it!
There's no way!
Twelve!
Yes!
The rag will make it?
No.
You deserve to be here.
Yeah!
Pineapple!
The pineapple majority reigns on 203.
203.
That's all that matters.
Two hundred.
All right, we have time for one more game.
We'll do one public lobby.
We'll have one for one last game and we'll do one public lobby for the last game.
Oh, that's been fun!
Huge shout-out again to the sponsor for sponsoring the stream.
I really appreciate it.
It's been a really fun time, especially playing with my dragons.
And the customization, the maps, the Battle Royale aspect.
I love Battle Royale.
I just love Battle Royale.
What can I say?
Apparently, they're adding more features later on.
Obviously, they're adding more updates, more costumes, more cosmetics, and everything.
But the ranking system is really interesting too.
The fact that they have a ranking system and everything.
Oh my god.
This is awesome.
It took so much.
The penguin anger.
The other non-pineapples.
It took so much out of me.
The gameplay sabotage, man.
The goddamn gameplay sabotage.
From all those non-pineapples.
The penguin road rage!
Oh my god.
I mean, that's basically it.
I mean, you're not wrong.
It's just penguin road rage.
And this is why I should not drive.
This is exactly why I shouldn't drive.
I should drive.
It's not like road rage.
Flare it up.
You penguin.
Oh my god.
That's such a cool pet.
Wait!
That's so cute!
That's such a cute penguin.
Get off my head.
I swear to god.
Get off my head!
There you go.
Wait.
How can I be on somebody's head?
I want to be on somebody's head.
No, no.
You cannot be on my head!
If I'm on somebody else's head!
No, I'm gonna be on...
There you go.
That's right.
Now it's my turn.
No!
Everybody wants to get on somebody's head!
Everyone's jumping up now.
No, no, no, no.
If anybody's gonna be on top, it's gonna be me.
Get over here.
I like how the...
Please!
I wanna be on top!
Why
does everybody else...
Oh, there you go.
That's right.
That's goddamn right.
Okay.
This is it, guys.
Guys, I gotta win.
Please.
Guys, mosh pit.
Guys, we can't let these non-dragoons win, guys.
We have to have a mosh pit strat.
We gotta work together.
Nice.
Alright.
We did it.
Oh!
Nice.
Okay.
We're doing it.
We figured it out, the tech.
We figured it out.
Oh, we're so good at this.
Oh, no, we're not so good at this.
We're figuring.
Please.
Please!
No!
Everybody was all grouped together.
Paraglider.
That's right.
Shouldn't have been grouped up together.
You gotta be outside the box, guys.
Y'all think outside the box.
If you all bunch up together, you miss out on the paraglider.
Wait, this map is cool.
Oh, god, no.
That's right.
You try to...
You're gonna be off your whale soon, and I'm gonna get you.
Oh, you know I know you're gonna be off your whale.
That's right.
What?
Shouldn't have activated your whale that early.
Now I'm...
Now I'm here to send a message.
Now I'm here.
Come on, come on.
No, no, no, no!
You fish!
It's okay.
We're calm.
We made it.
Yeah!
Where is he?
Where is this guy?
I remember his name.
Where is he?
This guy.
The non-pineapple.
Blow bubbles at him!
Blow...
All right.
Now we point and laugh at the people that couldn't make it.
Look at you.
Couldn't afford a ticket.
You fish!
Pineapple versus pineapple.
I'm surprised I made it this far.
I got to round one.
All the practice from you dragoons in the private lobbies really helped.
Now I'm a gamer.
Now I'm a goddamn gamer.
All right, guys.
Mosh pit.
Wait, there's an ice cream guy?
Get him out of this lobby.
He doesn't deserve it.
Get him out.
We all have to target him.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Mosh pit.
Nice.
Yes!
Oh, no!
I hit the thing!
It's okay.
We're still moshing.
The thing's gonna stop me.
Oh, yes.
Right.
You're in front.
Thank you for being in front of me.
That's good.
What the heck?
How did I?
Where did you guys come from?
Where'd all you guys come from?
Oh, no, no, no, no.
No, no!
Oh, come on.
Yes!
Oh, I missed?
But he was in front of me.
Paraglider, paraglider!
Yes!
Goodbye losers.
Haha.
Imagine being a ground penguin.
Couldn't be me.
Imagine being on the ground as a penguin.
What freaks.
What goddamn penguin freaks.
Okay, that's okay.
That's okay.
We're fine.
Yes!
Get out, get out.
Okay, that's not fair.
I like hit a barrier.
Fourth place, baby.
Me and my whale got fourth place, baby.
Did I scream too loud?
I think I made it.
Guys, this is our target.
I'm gonna blow bubbles.
Remember him.
This is our target.
He can't get...
Guys, we can't let him get anything.
We can't let the ice cream penguins win.
Guys, we can't.
Fourth.
Activity three.
Alright, two more rounds.
Two more rounds.
We gotta make sure the ice cream penguins...
Guys, as the pineapple, as leader of the pineapple penguin group, we have to make sure all the ice cream penguins don't have anything.
Like ingame though.
Like not toxic...wise though.
Like just...just like...ingame.
Alright, get out.
Get out.
Oh, no!
dyal...dyal dodyal...dyal dodyal dodyal..
cyn...cy mountains of it possibile Okay, I'm going to use you.
Penguin, get over here.
I need to use you.
Penguin, no!
We need to work together and then we win!
Wait, that's so cute.
She's using a bed to slide.
Hey guys, I finally got some sardines, guys.
I finally did it.
I got some sardines.
Oh, nice.
We need that.
Wait, no, that's not fair.
They have paragliders.
Wait, what?
What happened?
What happened to me?
That was so weird.
I got like bumped up everywhere.
Oh no, we're at 50%.
This is not good.
This is not good at all.
Oh no.
No.
No, please.
Oh, we made it.
We made it.
Did the ice cream guy made it?
Did the yellow ice cream guy made it?
Yes!
That's right!
The yellow ice cream guy made it!
We did our job!
Oh, wait.
There's a pink ice cream?
Where did the pink ice cream come from?
Nice.
It worked.
Targeted.
Targeted road rage worked.
Our lobby is safe now.
Guys, it's okay.
With no yellow ice cream, we're safe.
What did he do?
I don't know.
He's just...
He could have given us brain freeze, guys.
I saved the lobby.
I literally saved the lobby.
He could have... Oops.
I'm sorry, guys.
Okay.
Nice.
Bounty cleared.
Alright.
We're okay.
I'm not gonna go... I'm not gonna try the bomb thing again.
The bomb thing was a little too risky.
It was definitely way too risky.
Oh, my God.
That was close.
I almost... I almost thought that was like...
No!
Oh!
Oh, thank God.
He like used me... He used me to make sure I don't hit the bomb.
Thank God.
He bumped me out of the way.
Nice.
20%.
No!
Okay.
I'm gonna be like a horse and... and jump over these hoops.
Alright.
Nice.
Grab this.
Oh.
Grab him.
Nice.
Get over here.
Get over here, penguin.
No, but slow down.
Slow down.
I need to use you.
Slow down!
Please!
Oh, no.
Thank God.
Okay.
That's fine.
Wait.
That slows you down.
That actually slows you down.
Wait.
I can make it.
Yeah!
Six!
None
of the ice creams.
Oh, wait.
One ice cream made it.
We did it, guys.
Top ten.
And we got a pineapple in.
We're top five!
I like how... I like how one of them wailed, guys.
Let's go!
We got one of our own in!
Yeah!
Pineapple ready!
Our lobby is like 80% pineapple.
I like how our lobby was like 80% pineapple.
There's no...
There's no other...
There's no other desert players.
We just took over the lobby.
Yay!
Another medal!
Nice.
Oh, I got summer pine... Oh, wait.
Can I change colors?
Wait.
Can I change color?
Pineapple colors now?
Wait.
I can.
Oh, so that's how they change the colors.
Nice.
I see.
I still like the yellow, though.
I think the yellow is the cutest one.
Um...
Oh, the high five!
That was fun, though.
I'm gonna call it here.
Because we do have another stream later today.
But...
Thank you guys so much for coming to the sponsored stream with Fast Penguin!
Thank you again to Fast Penguin for sponsoring me.
And I hope you guys had a lot of fun playing.
Like I said, if you guys want to support the stream, if you want to support the sponsor...
Um... the game and everything...
Just use the link.
Um... and click the link and download the game.
Like I said, it is free to play.
It's free to play.
Uh... so there's no, like... you don't have to pay for anything.
You just, you know... go right in and play the game.
But anyway...
Uh... hope you guys had a great time.
Um...
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if it stayed up for me, I'm doing another stream later today.
Where we're announcing the winners for...
Uh... gamer subs.
Yeah!
Stick by for... stay up for that if you guys want to.
Um...
What else do I want to say?
It was very difficult to be PG, but I think I did my best.
Like...
I think...
I think we made it work.
Anyway, guys.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!